das ist ein bummel twitter klar dass sie
das so hallo an alle zur nächsten folge
von minecraft galaxy heute mit dem lokal
kontrastreichen hallo es ist ja sehr
sehr lang her dass wir zusammen wo bin
ich wo bin ich wo wir nicht ach ich
freue mich gerade wo ich mir ausgedacht
hat ich baue auf ihn zum baum im
niemandsland
ich bin einfach in der letzten folge
also ich bin ja so eine fledermaus und
kam deswegen ja fliegen und ich bin
einfach mal richtig aber es ist ja erst
am anfang wie was dieser dreck in
anführungszeichen der sich bei uns
folge wir haben gerade begrüßt die
unsere begrüßung zerstört hat dieser
test ja uns gerade begrüßt dann bist du
durch fast alle geschlagen
da war das ich habe knapp zwei jahren
anders gewesen haben schon gefragt wer
das war
ich hab dich wirklich als topf so hallo
an alle zu minecraft galaxy
aber da war ich noch keine fledermaus
doch dann war ich das nicht ich habe die
fledermaus erst seit einer folge und da
wart ihr nicht auf dem server dann war
das max max hat auch schon die sonne
geht auch nicht dass jeder maß für das
nicht unterstellen
die wahl wird nicht mal als peter moss
das war auch so schwer so eine blöde
fehler muss zu bekommen
ich meine ich bin jetzt allgemein nicht
so der beste pvp la und dann musste ich
so eine kleine chance heraus treffen
also ich hab gefühlte zehn jahre dafür
gebraucht das war unglaublich ja der
letzten folge gegen so eine rein und hab
dann zufällig eine gesehen hatten
todesmutige sprung nach unten beachten
einfach weg und ist gestorben
nein ich habe die fehler muss erst noch
eine richten
habt ihr euch eigentlich schon mit der
mit dem transport auseinandergesetzt
also damit könnt ihr euch ab waffen
machen allerdings braucht man für waffen
diese buttons box hilfe dieser web
missbrauchs braucht man kakteen um das
zu kräften und ich hätte nie gedacht
weist er im normalen vanilla minecraft
liegt sich nicht mal eben kurz zwei
minuten und findet eine wüste aber hier
da es sich um 10.000
ja das ist so schwer einfach diese
normalen immer wieder zu finden
ich will einfach dem wüste aber ich
finde keine nochmal genau was genau
wollte zumal die wüste rein auf ihren
kapitän baur ich für was das für die
weapons box und mit der weapons box kann
man sich dann sachen gebracht wie eine
ak-47 oder so gehen ich wollte mich
gerade zurückverwandeln volt game mode
eintippen stark machen ja ich fange mit
etwas anderen bisschen gentechnik
vielleicht um zwischen rechtlichen zum
ausprobieren
nee das ist aber relativ simpel da
braucht man nur acht level 4 man kann es
nicht schon beschweren weil da kann man
erstmal ressourcen holen und was hältst
du davon wenn man es vielleicht ein
bisschen weg machen und mal so nach
grundstücken suchen dass man beim ausbau
und kann meist wenn sie so eine pampa
stehst was der kommission ihr ich hab
ich hab' ich habe mich in sonnenberg
rhein gebaut und ich habe von der
perfekten ist also neben mir ist als
üblich in der stadt ich zeigt im moment
ich brauchte er ganz kurzen moment da
vorne ist unsere stadt
ich seh schon unser hauptgebäude nee das
ist ein anderes gebäude
das geht aus insel sag mir einfach mal
wo bist du gerade das ist ja sehr schön
dass wir gewinnen können
ein sitz und rahmen ich stehe wenn du
auf der karte kux bei da ist so eine
hütte neben unserem spawn haus etwas
weiter rechts siehst du so ein
angebautes haus was geradezu ambauen ist
und etwas weiter rechts siehst du so
eine hütte wo schon das dach fertig ist
und da dahinter so ein paar blicke bin
ich schon
ja also südlich dann also nach unten
runden hüttl und zwischen dem kreisel er
da ist und er hätte genau dein bitte bei
diesem 1 ich bin
wenn ich auf der unserer startete vor
der tür stehe und er aus der tür raus
gucken wo dann hin in welche richtung
dann nach links nach links okay ich sehe
die wirte da siehst du dann die hütte
ja und wenn du weiter nach runter gehst
siehst du dann so einen komischen
steinkreis einen steinkreis a
ich finde die 14 naja das kind eingehen
ich komme als zu dir ich finde ich auch
fledermaus nicht richtig macht aber ich
wollte etwas anderes einsammeln hier das
ist voll gefertigte tausend sachen
gleichzeitig machen
ich hab nämlich für fledermäuse und
gerade ich habe mit meiner weitere
fledermaus gefunden und von den werde
ich jetzt mehr hautschuppen hoch also
bisher bist du willst du in diesem wald
mit diesen kleinen bäume diesen ganz
vielen kleinen oder mit diesen ganz
großen mit den ganz großen mama dann
dann dann habe ich dich mensch dass ich
dann wo ja gar nicht so weit auseinander
entfernt voneinander entfernt so warte
ich stehe auf also ich hab ja noch kein
haus gemacht ich bin hier einfach nur so
just for fun gerade genesen kann dem
platz meter ich werde jetzt dna-spuren
von einer fledermaus extrahieren
dna-spuren dna-spuren erwarte aber ist
der steinkreis ok perfekt schön da
dazwischen irgendwo ich bin bei diesem
blauen punkt bei dem steinkreis finde
fledermaus also greife nicht an das
achte das wasser einfach hallo hallo sie
hier
ich weiß nicht so eine fledermaus zu
sehen ist relativ schiff ja ich sehe
dich du bist auch im sternbild widder
morus partie hin
also ich hab ich erstmal nur einen
kleinen tunnel gebaut um halt rein kann
und dann meinen kann baute ärzte hast du
es schon gemacht mit dem indiens da habe
ich schon
also ja dafür braucht man auch einfach
achten level brauchst acht level und
dann drückst du mal die taste aber ich
glaube sie musste erst um legen weil die
hat man glaub ich ein telefon an also
mein telefon ich kann mein handy melden
wegschmeißen ich hätte fast mein bett
nicht getroffen weil sie nicht gerade
mein handy ist auf jeden fall weg welche
da muss ich die taste umlegen
die taste musste und controls gehen und
dann musst du bei dem mord von mini on
what was anderes ankreuzen alster oder
kann ich habe jetzt mal eingenommen oder
ich hab dann okay ich nehme auch mal ein
apostroph okay und jetzt habe ich komme
tui will oder nicht wann mein okay ich
brauche jetzt mal acht level ich habe
nur vier weltgeschichte freute sich
gerade echt schon schlagen du bist das
versucht die ganze dir von die
hautschuppen zu extremen ich hab gesagt
hey warum geht wie ich wie hautschuppen
zu extrahieren
man kann doch mal hat jesus creator
damit kann man an tieren kratzen und den
hautschuppen extrahieren und dann kann
man später dann damit die dna
analysieren und sich die fähigkeiten
darauf ziehen dann kann ich später zum
beispiel auch ohne fledermaus gestalt
als zu meiner spieler fleder klappern
wenn ich mir nämlich von der fledermaus
die die die gene spritze ok kohl muss
ich auch noch machen merkt schon ein
bisschen ordnung hiervon ja ich habe
dazu schon mal eine verstellung glaube
ich gemacht wenn ich mich das wollte ich
schon immer mal wissen und zwar wenn ich
mich in ein zb ein skelett verwandeln ja
schließlich ein anderes geräte ab oder
denken die soja oder ein freund von uns
ob durchblick als fledermaus rum und die
werden auch abgeschossen und ich wurde
auch schon ein paar mal abgeschossen
ich nehme an das gilt nicht so wirklich
die sehen nicht trotzdem bisher kleiner
und schwerer zu treffen als weder moor
schule in mesum ansonsten könnte diese
kleine redbox kannst du auch irgendwas
empfehlen an ärzten die ich am besten
einfach nicht mitnehmen bräuchte weil
ich die eferding das problem von den
ärzten genau wie man die sachen kraft
weiß ich nicht bis jetzt mit dem motto
items auseinandergesetzt das heißt
welche was man mit dem machen kann diese
kraft natürlich angeschaut das habe ich
nehme einfach alles getan
okay gut das war bisher auch meine
taktik weil ich hab mal wo ich bin von
dieser cube traf modifikation also von
der kommt diese ganzes quantum
allerdings bin ich sehr angetan wenn ich
mir dann kann man hier nämlich portale
machen und beispielsweise wenn du denkst
okay mein haus ist langweilig ich will
dass also meine um eine region ist
langweilig ich will mein haus
woandershin haben kannst einfach ein
ganzes haus weg porten damit quasi das
fände ich halt nicht ganz so ganzes haus
weg weg frames dieser hatte diesen
quantum kraft sachen das ist zwar alles
sehr sehr schwer zu kräften und so was
alles aber du musst halt quasi einfach
nur um dein haus so vier blöcke setzen
und dann wird der komplette dank halt
irgendwo anders hin kopiert also dem
sich die schubkraft modifikation ist wie
ich denke aber das müsste eigentlich der
fall sein
von daher freue ich mich übelst darauf
diese modifikation dass die einfach
benutzen kann
das ist richtig ich hätte hier klicken
silicon.de silikon zu müssen
die spritzen wie die fledermaus gene
publikum
diese liegen für diese gene led das netz
erscheint auch skelett ist unglaublich
nervig hab mich die ganze ist ja
unglaublich das ist ja ich habe noch nie
so ein skelett erlebt das hat sich
irgendwas gespritzte ohne spaß das ist
ja nicht normal so noch gar nicht wie
genau ich meine also ich kann die
gleiche zeigen dann kann ich dir so ein
bisschen so zeigen wo ich wohne ich bin
nämlich gleiche level achter macht das
einfach mal legen fest was bei münchen
fest
ich finde diese wasser sonst sehr cool
also ich habe jetzt hier zum beispiel
auch kein shader reingemacht
so bist du so ein bisschen neutral
gehalten weil er über ladet manchmal ein
bisschen viel und bei dem so war ich
aber ich mache es komme tui will ja
stimmen
remo niemand irgendwas aussuchen wenn du
glücklich wäre einfach zdf das hat sich
gefährlich an ok ich hab' blacks
normalerweise nein es kommt
und normalerweise sagte auch noch was
kann der master report viewer was ich
oma opa oder sowas dann kriegst all
diesen zauberstab genug falls das rating
great
ist ein stoff bekommen eine musik wird
gespielt als episch gleich ob minecraft
noch nie so episch erlebt doch folgt bei
mir gab es das glaub ich hab keinen stab
liegt es vielleicht daran dass man
inventar voll war hast doch wirklich
acht level bezahlt wird muss das
mehrmals machen
also ich hab jetzt drei level bezahlt
dann musst du noch mal machen nochmal
auf alter alles kalt mich an die natur
hast mich das ist unglaublich
alle pflanzen alles auf was ich drauf
trägt die skelette ist sehr klar wenn du
auch was drauf drückt dann hat das links
sehr logisch wer will schon gern
zerquetscht werden
so warte ich schmeiße jetzt einfach mal
so ein paar sachen weg hier so jetzt hab
ich im freien slot
jetzt macht das ganze noch mal er
kommentiere nelsons amborn okay ich
halte hier läuft auf manege um die
hatten computer aufmarsch vermittelt
mest nichts zu gehörten gelacht ich habe
stark ja das kommt mit der zeit habe ich
gar nicht so gut was sollte mir sagen ja
ich stelle steht die esel haben computer
auf dem arsch im wahrsten sinne des
wortes und esel der hat einen computer
authentisch als ehrlich renten esel rum
und er hat einfach auf seinem computer
stehen ich hab gerade jetzt abgebaut und
was kommt raus ein buch mit eigenen
kräften dingen sind so ich freue mich
jetzt mal wieder zurück wie eine
fledermaus nicht dass ich angreifen
ich habe jetzt gerade meinen heimgesucht
so einem kleinen bisschen weiter nach
unten
an den bäumen vorbei und versuchte mal
so ein grundstück jetzt abzustecken
mit einem grundstück so einer bis hier
schön ja ein bisschen platz schaffen wir
haben so viel fläche hier da kann man
auch ein bisschen etwas größeres
grundstück sich abstecken
er habe echt große fläche also es ist
nicht so nah beim mega projekt für das
die hütchen also in die hütchen ich kann
dir gleich nochmal allerdings zeige ich
wollte mich so richtig cool im berg ein
baum ganz der glas machen dass ich über
lync gucken kann und
wenn ich mir das so wenn das wird wie
ich mir vorstellen jetzt cool aber es
wird nicht so wie es mir vorstelle mit
riesen glas von wo drauf schauen kannst
ja von wo ich raus ja ja genau jetzt
nicht schlechter hier sind überall
verwelkte blumen versuchslabor zu machen
sehr viel
ach so aussah 4 kann man nicht kann ich
mir auch so sachen machen sowie eine
spitzhacke ich glaub ich weiß ich hab
das noch vom viele liebsten noch drin
ist kann sein
ich würde mich schon darauf habe ich
nicht ob dazu gegriffen so ich schaue
mal ganz kurz auf und noch was ist ich
bin einfach grad und in einer höhle
nicht dass dich das stört oder so dann
mache ich hab einfach nur ein gebot so
gerade so einfach so durchleuchtet dass
mich ein bisschen aus krass ist einfach
dass ich noch gar keine diamanten
gefunden habe nicht die kids ihren
tollen gewinnen und ein erdhaufen findet
hängt gleich mal hier 16 diamanten
deutschen aufgefallen ich war auf einem
reisen ab und dann sind also nicht mehr
gut also ja klar standard sehen wir
interessante neue bei dem objekt zu
welchen gründen auch immer
naja er sich beschwere mich deswegen
nicht aber du brauchst du waren sehr
viele ressourcen ist glaube ich auch
viel zu helfen die wegen ganzen moz das
alles zusammen zu fahren
deswegen ist das eine gute alternative
also find ich schon das wird gerade
zufällig im bett oben im haus von uns im
kornhaus sind welcher wir können schnell
hinfliegen da wer fledermäuse sind geht
das komm komm zu mir die bude
wenn du zum spot aus fliegt von dir dann
müsste ich ja meine bude vorbei fliegen
können okay probierte man diese blöde
leiter hier aber wenig wenn ich eine
fledermaus mit zwei betten trainer habe
ich glaube ich habe wolle dass du dir
noch eins machen kannst oder du nimmst
die einst aus dem spawn haus mit der ich
fliege macht gleich bis zum spawn haus
da kann ich ja weg widmen haus zeigen
was bisher einfach eine höhle ist da wo
wir prüfen jetzt gerade noch ich bin
jetzt bei mir im haus ist so
ausgeleuchtet in sonneberg drin
warte ich verwandeln nicht aus mainz ich
bin schon da guck mal ich bin jetzt
trivial den habe ich schon getötet ja
sofort bevor das ganze projekt losging
hatte ich den schon getötet weil da
waren wir alle so komisch gespannt und
dann
ob ich dann einfach getötet und ich
glaube müssen die folge auch jetzt
beenden bevor wir schlafen gehen oder
wir gehen mit den bändern voll
geschlafen habe ich winke eingeweide
feld geplündert einfach sofort zum
gemeinschaftshaus und nicht wieder neue
bestands berlin termin war auch selbst
dass auch heftig krass ich war als
fledermaus verkleidet und hat mich dann
einfach zum schlafen irgendwie wieder
als ich gemacht weil ich fand wenn so
eine fledermaus steht das irgendwie
durfte ich bin dann ach ich bin ich
krieche wieder die blöde mensch läuft
sagt ich bin dann einfach von meiner ich
würde ja so ein bisschen erhöht nap bin
dann etwa darunter gesprungen todesmutig
dachte ich werde fledermaus wollte
fliegen und es ging nicht wenn wenig
halt vor augen gehabt aber da war wasser
und das war so schön wenn man ihm
herunter guckt ich mein ganzes haus
umgeben von wasser mehr oder weniger das
ganz schön da kann ich da rein springen
ich hab übrigens auch schon paar lustige
mavs gesammelt einerseits eine kleine
ein kleiner baum sondern antrag
eigentlich glauben ich komme wieder und
so ein tentakel fies und alien
tintenfisch oder hat nicht richtig war
auch einfach zornig hat sich als
tintenfisch verwandelt und bummelt ist
klar ich habe somit alle abgebaut und
auf 14 rausgekommen auch ein
getreidefeld sagte jetzt kommt das
gruselige raus und denke dass sie das
wie gary ja nicht ganz ist keine
schneckenpost wirklich aus wie sein weil
sie nicht diese fossil teile die man bei
pokemon mal erschaffen kommt jetzt jetzt
bis zu dieser maßnahme findet sowieso
zwei fledermäuse fliegen hier wird
richtig ja und die gleichen länder
drachen wir uns gleich aufrissen da
steht wirklich ändert eure alter aber
ich glaube dass de france oder
der hat den grünen hat das müsste er von
cream sein weil tim roth im wohnt hier
ist sie in unserem team ist rwe auch ich
komme sich einander immer mit den teams
ein anderes realistisch gewesen
wir sind über 15 minuten deswegen weil
ich gerade schon werden nach magadan x17
ist ja noch okay dann machen hier einen
kleinen stopp wir sehen uns im nächsten
bad und dann ja müsste ich noch alles
gut sein sollten keiner kofferpacken bis
zum nächsten mal